>>Jay: This circuit
consists of a speaker,
so you can hear the sounds
when they're made,
a battery for power.
If we were to hook the circuit
up to itself with no resistor...
[ high-pitched tone ]
...you'll get that
constant frequency.
If we disconnect the circuit,
then we can hook it
to another resistor.
So, in the case of water...
[ tone descends and ascends ]
...it's a variable resistor.
This circuit sends electrons
through the blue alligator clip
and creates that wave
that makes a sound.
Well, what else is a resistor?
Well, the whole world
is a resistor.
>>Jay: So, I'll just start.
I'm Jay Silver, and what we're
going to talk about today
and work with today is that
the world that we live in,
meaning cats, grandmas, rain,
your computer, your shoes,
everything in the world,
is a construction kit.
>>Jay: It's like the whole
education system is locked
down from some ancient, you
know, 100-year-old idea,
except for kindergarten.
The very word itself
literally means "child garden."
It means create an environment
where people can mess about.
>>Jay: We're going to forget
that cans are for holding food,
and we're going to make cans
and everything else
here do something else.
We're going to give
them our own purpose.
And so, the first really quick
exercise, each group is going
to grab some junk,
and we're going
to make some geometric shape.
>>Jay: The way kindergarten
was designed was a set
of what we would call toys,
so, blocks, finger paint,
certain geometrical
shapes, and hoops.
These things help children
at the appropriate developmental
stage of 5 or 6 relate ideas.
What's the appropriate
developmental tools or toys
for a 13-year-old to
learn, share, iterate,
flourish, mess up, get excited?
>>I have a marrot triangle.
>>The Leaning Tower of Flowers.
>>Jay: So, you call it blocks?
>>Yeah.
>>Jay: Great.
>>Jay: I want someone
as soon as possible
to have a successful experience
with something open-ended
so that they can look back
and say to themselves,
"I have accomplished whatever
it is we're trying to get."
>>Jay: If I touch one
side of the circuit
and then the other side...
[ circuit squeaks ]
...it squeaks, okay?
And if I touch it harder...
[ squeak ascends ]
...it squeaks higher,
and if I touch it less...
[ squeak descends ]
...it squeaks lower.
Let's make a little
instrument out of this.
The simplest instrument you
can make is with two people.
>>Jay: The way I believe
people learn is by carrying
out their own processes
in the physical world.
>>Jay: So, hold her hand.
Now -- yeah, there you go.
[ circuit squeaks ]
And now, hold tighter.
There you go.
Yeah.
[ circuit squeaks ]
>>Jay: I'm only going to teach
people by creating a situation
where people can then carry
out meaningful projects.
>>Jay: Let's show how you can
invent with a circuit like this.
Let's take a piece of string.
This is just regular yarn.
We can dope the string
with a certain type
of conductive material,
in this case, water.
So, I just dip the
string into water.
[ various tones play ]
>>Jay: I can even get vibrato.
[ vibrato tones play ]
>>Jay: Leaves can
be like buttons.
[ various tones play ]
>>Jay: Everyday objects are
in a class of their own, and,
in a sense, anything can be
cast as an everyday object.
But the important thing
about everyday objects is
that people have
familiarity with them.
>>Jay: What you do with the
MaKey MaKey is you take junk,
you hook it up to your computer,
and you can control your
computer with the junk.
So, let me show you a
little more about that.
>>Jay: But my windows, my house,
you know, my relationships
with people, that's
how inventors think.
That's how artists who
push the limit think.
It's the same as how
scientists make new discoveries.
Scientists don't think
of the scientific method.
They're trying to
push what's possible.
>>Jay: So, I'm going to start
by taking a piece of some tofu
that I was just eating.
Oh, actually, I ate
all the tofu.
I'll have to take the cornbread.
So, you hook up the cornbread to
one of these four buttons or one
of these spacer clips.
So, I'm touching the
cornbread, the video starts.
I touch it again,
the video stops.
>>Jay: If you take
everyday supermarket stuff
and you give a catalyst,
in this case, you know,
electronic duct tape,
like a MaKey MaKey,
you have just changed,
technology changed
everyday objects,
and now you have
changed yourself,
because you have this
creative confidence
that comes from this experience.
>>Jay: Over the next 90 minutes,
we're going to work
towards making an invention.
You're going to make, you
know, stairs into a piano
or you're going to make your
bench into a Pac-Man controller
or you're going to take a
book and when you open it,
it's going to send an email.
Something is going to happen
when you touch something.
>>Jay: You might ask, "Is
this about making a scientist,
or is this about making
someone who's resourceful
and can address problems
in multiple ways?"
And, well, I don't think
there's any difference
between those two questions.
>>What are you guys
working with over here?
>>Having
trouble making it work.
>>Oh!
What kind of troubles?
>>Jay: I think people
have the wrong idea
of what scientists do.
A scientist is a
resourceful person
who keeps attacking problems
and fails 99 times out of 100.
>> It's like a bird.
See, it's like a flapping bird.
It's like a bird.
>>Jay: I see there's two people
playing it at the same time.
>>Student: Mash it once...
[ computer voice ]
and there’s a voice.
>>And I've
got more of 'em.
[ potatoes play piano sounds ]
>> This is up, this is right,
this is left, and this is down.
Here we go, "Dance
Dance Revolution."
[ music plays ]
I'm not that good,
so don't laugh at me.
>>Jay: If a kid comes
to you with a question,
to assume that you have
the answer is to assume
that life is really simple.
But it's not true.
If a little kid comes to you and
asks you, "Why is the sky blue,"
why may know something
about scattering of light,
you may think you know that
it reflects off the ocean,
but all of that doesn't matter.
The point is, it's about the
process of them being curious!
So, don't try to
give them answers.
Try to give them curiosity.
So, when someone says,
"Why is the sky blue,"
you say, "I wonder!
I wonder why.
It's really -- it's a
really multi-faceted thing.
I wonder why."